what are you doing you're forming a
supergroup with Brandi Carlile Wow
so who's in that group you Brandi and
who else our friend Natalie hem B who
has written the star is born' soundtrack
amanda shires who's married to Jason
Isbell she's an incredible songwriter
and fiddle player and yeah like we were
just in the studio or recording with
Dave Cobb who did the Stapleton records
and where do you recorded you go to over
her far more like that yeah she's I
would love to go out to the Seattle and
see her place but no yeah let's go
sounds like fun over there all the whole
band lives around her it's like it's a
whole scene you know it looks like a
postcard
she's pretty phenomenal - yeah she's
just an angel you actually catch me
during her Grammy performance like
saying the f-word I was just I didn't
realize the camera was on me but I was
just like yeah and you just saw a star
being born like the whole world knowing
who she was that was the best moment at
the Grammys we're not I was so emotional
for her because you could see how into
it she was like this is my chance yeah
she just completely slayed it and
everyone knew who she was after that
performance but she's like you you know
I could see why you guys like would like
each other because you know you're both
been working at it a really long time
and you're getting your recognition and
you know you're not just a country
artist you're more than that
yeah and nothing's overnight so what
you'd like to write with her - you sit
down are you intimidated or you just
kind of just dive right in
you're probably used to write with other
people so it's not a big deal I am yeah
and so is she
and so no she's she's lovely she's her
compass for songs it's just so good and
she's probably got unparalleled one of
the best voices in the world have you
harmonized with her yet oh yeah this
whole project with the high women is
very very vocal driven so it's a
pleasure to harmonize with Miss Brandi
Carlile and it's all women it was
important that that be all women there's
been a pretty severe drought of women in
country music being played on the radio
the last ten years and so I think we're
just trying to show that women can
support other women and not be cutthroat
and lift each other up and it not be
this kind of there's only a few spots so
we have to fight them out mentality and
it's been
just such a pleasure to be in the studio
with those gals and the songs you know I
just have rough mixes of them right now
but they're they're really incredible